les positions russes en ligne de mire
bombarder l'ennemi voilà la consigne
depuis plusieurs semaines
deux à trois fois par jour en tirant
toute la charge de munitions environ 50
à 60 coups par jour bien sûr nous tirons
sur les véhicules d'infanterie légère et
les troupes au sol les Russes ne
déploient pas leur équipement militaire
lourd
la contre-offensive lancée par Kiev
semble bien fonctionner puisqu'à près 8
mois d'occupation les Russes en Europe
toutes les mesures pour assurer le
transfert en toute sécurité du personnel
des armes et du matériel à travers le
fleuve Nièvre André donné d'établir une
nouvelle ligne de défense à l'est du
Nièvre cette fois sur la rive gauche du
fleuve la défaite russe était en réalité
déjà pressenti face à l'avancée des
troubles ukrainienne le Kremlin avait
déjà procédé au déplacement de
population civile quelques 115 000
personnes avait ainsi été évacué de la
région Carson pour être ensuite conduite
vers l'est du pays vers les territoires
contrôlés par Moscou la président
ukrainienne a de son côté indiqué ce
mercredi soir ne voit aucun signe de
retrait des forces russes de redstone et
sa région